what exactly is it noodling where they
put their hand in a pipe that has a fish
in it and they get the fish out well
it's like uh it's like a mud it's like
underwater like a lake or a [ __ ]
river
[Laughter]
it's okay the girls where's my shirt
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
boys in the mountains sign off on this
they're not little boys and from looking
for some noodles they in the noodle son
[Laughter]
and why do you also put his hands on
[Laughter]
yeah this little Christmas Christmas
bunny little Christmas critter huh oh
but he's not in the shot huh no man in
the shot they clearly don't know if he's
trying to feel on these my shirt off and
feel on them boys Harley dudes the
catcher son wanna have a seat that's
crazy I doubt he signed off on that full
body what do you mean you don't show up
to something looking like that if you
didn't plan on it
this is tinder profile pic very tender
dude that is rare food let him live man
let him live he's living doing a damn
thing and he used to probably be a train
conductor obviously and here he is man
obviously we lives in one of those
Christmas villages that our grandparents
owned gosh I thought this dude died in
the Andrea Gail this
[Music]
King nothing
[Music]